i've done targets before hit targets
that were just it was wrong and and that
was a huge lesson learned for me i hit a
target one time my first deployment to
iraq and
and pulled the thread on the because i
got back thinking that was not right
like that that person the guy that we
got is not a bad guy he clearly was not
a bad guy and it came back and started
pulling the thread hey who who did this
who gave us this information and
eventually pulled the thread and it was
um like he had his wife had fired the
maid
or something like that it was something
like that the maid was pissed
and so she went and started telling
americans that oh yeah this guy he's a
bad guy he's financing you know that
kind of thing um
and so that was a huge lesson for me
because from then on
my question would be who put this x on
this building because that's what we
would literally get would be a a map and
there'd be an x on the building a red x
just like a movie a red x on a building
and i would say who'd put that red x
there
i want to know who put that red x and i
would pull the thread and find out
exactly hey this is the information that
we've got this is what's corroborated
it's really really hard
and if you're not in that mode and
there's pressure
that's where these people make these um
quick calls
to to try and do something and
you know again i don't i'll i want to
pull the threat on that more and
hopefully i can try and as it becomes
declassified because i'm sure some of
it's classified where they're getting
information from all that stuff can be
classified but it'll be interesting to
pull the threat on that and see why they
pulled the trigger on on that mission
and the report came back saying nobody
was responsible nobody was held
accountable it was just a mistake that
that they couldn't sort of pin to one
person was the pentagon report on it i
thought how is that how is that possible
you know how is nobody held accountable
to this at all
well you know even for me
when we hit that target and cap caught
this guy thank god we didn't shoot him
thank god he didn't resist he didn't
resist because he wasn't a bad guy so we
went we grabbed this guy but
the reason i wanted was so engaged with
that was because
i knew it was me
hey i'm the one that's kicking in the
door and we're you know well my team is
doing that so i need to take ownership
of what we're doing and
make sure that this is the right thing
to do in the right situation
because
yeah i mean so
if they're if you're allowed to sort of
push
responsibility onto 14 different people
that all had a hand in the intel
gathering which a bunch of people do
gather that intel but who's pulling the
trigger who's saying yes go and you need
to own that if you make that mistake and
explain why and then you can put some
procedures in place that
won't let it happen again
and also you have to question a little
bit
you have the inspector general of the
air force investigating the air force
like you know
would it be better to have an
independent person looking at this as
opposed to
having somebody investigate themselves i
don't know i i don't it's just sort of a
question that i've asked myself
and there's another thing that can
happen as well
and this was a term that i first heard
when i was in iraq my second deployment
good shot bad result
meaning when you lay out what happened
what a
individual saw like if the person that
pulled the trigger what he saw what he
understood what he was thinking you lay
all those things out
and you say you know what
you that was a good shot i understand
why you took that shot i'm sorry that
this is what happened
but
we at least we at least investigate and
say okay how did this happen
how did this occur
and how do we make sure that first of
all the person wasn't being negligent
the person's not trying to hide anything
because look when you're in war
you're going to shoot people and
occasionally you're going to shoot
someone that didn't deserve to get shot
that happens and when that happens you
have to actually look at it and say okay
how did it happen how did you make that
decision
why did you make that decision what did
you see you pull all that stuff apart
and
with my guys
the couple times that something like
this happened it was hey i understand
why you took that shot and and
it was actually the right call and i'm
it's horrible that has a bad result
but i understand why you did it and it
made sense
you know that's a lot different than oh
wait a second you didn't see anything
that looked suspicious or you
you know why did you shoot this well i
don't know no never got that answer and
never was in those situations so
for to your point
for to pull the threat on the whole
thing if someone said hey this is what
we saw this is the vehicle that we were
targeting this is the intel hit that we
got this is what our informant said this
is what our electronic surveillance said
they could actually paint a picture
where you say
you know in that pressure situation i
understand what you did i understand why
you took that shot and you took the risk
at taking that shot so you could save
americans and save an attack i
understand that
okay now we we at least learn something
but to just say um
nothing
it doesn't make sense
it's not it's not the right move man
freaking horrible